Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
Je ne sais pas vous,
mais moi j’ai toujours pensé
que les institutions ne sont pas
des lieux mais des esprits.
Je crois même que les institutions sont
assimilables à des organismes vivants.
Elles peuvent bouger, se déplacer,
et parfois même faire un pas de côté.
Vous savez déjà,
au moment où je vous parle,
que je suis directeur
de la Villa Médicis à Rome.
Vous venez de l’entendre dire,
ou bien vous l’avez lu à l’instant
sous le clip qui passe devant vous.
Vous pensez certainement savoir
qu’un musée est un lieu de culture.
Mais pendant les quelques minutes
qu’on va passer ensemble,
j’aimerais vous raconter qu’un musée
n’est pas qu’un lieu de culture,
un musée peut aussi être
un acteur économique et social
dont on peut mesurer l’impact.
Je n'ai pas toujours dirigé des musées.
Pendant douze ans, j’étais
commissaire d’exposition indépendant,
et, très vite, producteur
des expositions que je concevais.
En fait, j'avais trouvé le grain
de sable en quelque sorte.
Un musée n’est pas capable
de produire lui-même
les quatre expositions
qu’il doit présenter chaque année.
Normalement, les musées se vendent
ou se louent entre eux les expositions.
Ils en conçoivent une ou deux chaque année
et ils en ont besoin d’une
ou deux autres clés en main.
Si vous arrivez à pénétrer ce cercle-là
et à faire une offre pertinente,
eh bien, c’est gagné.
Content du modèle
que j’avais mis en place,
je concevais un projet
pendant une ou deux années,
je le produisais ensuite pendant une année
et je l’exploitais ensuite
pendant quelques années.
La phase d’exploitation me servait
à financer le nouveau projet,
et ainsi de suite.
Mes derniers gros projets étaient
dédiés à Charlie Chaplin et à Fellini -
vous voyez les affiches à l’écran.
Chacune a tourné à peu près
une trentaine de fois.
Une exposition comme celles-ci
était amortie
au bout de la troisième présentation.
J’aurais pu continuer comme cela
pendant longtemps, mais...
Mais je suis devenu directeur
du musée de l’Élysée,
musée de la photographie
de Lausanne, en Suisse.
Je n’étais plus à partir de ce moment-là,
mercenaire des expositions
que je proposais,
mais je devenais
responsable d’une programmation.
À la tête d’un musée,
vous êtes responsable
de l’exposition qui est présentée,
mais aussi de l’exposition d’avant
et de l’exposition d’après.
En quelque sorte, vous défendez
une ligne, une vision, un projet.
Et puis surtout, il y a le public.
A la tête d'un musée, vous devenez
responsable aussi de votre public.
Or, il n'y a pas un public,
mais des publics.
Repartons du début.
Qu’est-ce qu’un musée ?
Un musée,
c’est finalement un intermédiaire,
un trait d’union entre un projet
artistique d’un côté et le public.
Faire une bonne programmation,
en quelque sorte,
c’est faire 50% du chemin.
Le public, c'est les 50% restants.
Son public, il faut le connaître
sur le bout des doigts.
Il faudrait presque connaître
chaque visiteur par son prénom.
Le public de Lausanne, par exemple,
c’était un public habituel de musée :
un public éduqué, sérieux,
peut-être un peu plus jeune qu’ailleurs
parce qu’il s’agissait de photographie.
Mais à Lausanne, comme dans
beaucoup d’autres lieux d’ailleurs,
on ne touche que très rarement le public
qui n’ose pas entrer dans le musée.
On pourrait à partir de là, créer
un bel aphorisme, une lapalissade,
qui se déclinerait comme ça :
« On ne touche
que le public qui vous connaît. »
On pourrait d’ailleurs
se satisfaire de cet adage.
C’est la position un peu docte
du musée comme lieu de savoir.
Mais il faut prendre
à contre-pied les institutions,
il faut bousculer les lignes.
Que dit le public
qui ne vient pas au musée ?
En substance, il dit :
« On n’a pas les codes,
alors on préfère ne pas y aller. »
Et que répond le musée dans ce cas-là ?
Il répond à peu près ceci :
« Eh bien, très bien, restez chez vous. »
Mais on pourrait rajouter : « Restez
dehors et le musée viendra à vous. »
C'est ce qu'on a fait à Lausanne.
On est sorti du musée, on a lancé
« La Nuit des images »,
une grande soirée festive,
populaire et gratuite
où la photographie s’installait
dans les jardins du musée toute la nuit.
Ce soir-là, le musée restait, lui,
ouvert et gratuit pour tous.
On a En quelque sorte introduit
une dimension festive
dans la sphère muséale.
On a introduit de la convivialité
dans l’enceinte du musée,
qui est trop souvent perçu
comme austère, parfois un peu poussiéreux.
En quatre ans, la fréquentation a doublé.
On a travaillé de front tous les publics.
On a fait du musée « a place to see »,
« a place to be », « a place to be seen ».
Voilà, en bon français.
J’aurais pu rester
au musée de l’Élysée des années.
Après tout, j’étais assimilé
à un fonctionnaire helvétique,
poste à vie et salaire confortable.
Mais j’aime la liberté
et pouvoir entreprendre.
La créativité et le confort,
vous le savez,
font parfois mauvais ménage.
Alors, au bout de cinq ans,
j’ai quitté le monde des musées
pour celui des festivals.
On est en 2014 et je deviens
directeur des Rencontres d’Arles,
le festival de photographie.
Dès lors, mon projet n’est plus
à l’échelle d’un lieu, le musée,
mais à l’échelle d’une ville, Arles.
Le terrain de jeu devenait immense.
À Lausanne, j’avais bien appris la leçon :
introduire du festif dans le muséal.
Eh bien, à Arles,
j’allais faire l’opposé :
mettre de la rigueur dans un lieu festif.
La fête à Arles, elle était bien là,
Mais il fallait renforcer le contenu,
créer du sens,
prendre le prétexte
des expositions de photographies
pour offrir un regard sur l’état du monde,
programmer sur une plus longue échéance,
donner plus de temps
aux commissaires d’exposition
pour qu’ils proposent
des contenus inédits.
Le festival, c’est près
de 35 expositions en même temps.
En une saison, cela représente huit ans
de la programmation d’un musée.
À Arles, j’ai développé
ce que j’avais appris à Lausanne.
Je savais déjà
qu’une institution culturelle
est bien évidemment un acteur culturel.
Vous vous souvenez ?
C’est le point numéro un de mon exposé.
Mais j’ai surtout appris
qu’une institution
est aussi un acteur économique,
avec un impact fort sur son territoire,
et qu’elle crée du lien social.
Il ne faut pas être expert en finances
pour comprendre
que les Rencontres de la photographie,
pour la ville d’Arles,
c’est le meilleur investissement qui soit.
Les hôtels, les restaurants, les taxis
et même les coiffeurs vous le diront.
Pendant tout l’été, le festival
fait tourner leurs boutiques.
Chaque année, la ville verse au festival
une subvention de 300 000€
et le retour à la ville,
c’est 30 millionsd’euros.
Car les visiteurs restent
en moyenne 4,5 jours.
Et pendant ces 4,5 jours, ils dorment,
ils déjeunent, ils dînent, ils consomment.
Pour le monde de la culture,
les statistiques sont assez précises :
1€ investi, c’est 7€ de retour
à l’économie locale.
À Arles, ce chiffre monte même à 10€.
Effectivement,
300 000€ investis par la ville
pour un retour de 30 millions.
À Arles, j’ai appris
qu’une institution culturelle
possède un facteur d’attractivité
qu’elle se doit de connaître,
de maîtriser et, le cas échéant,
de développer.
Je dois vous dire que je n’aime pas
beaucoup ce mot d’attractivité,
car il incarne une vision
extrêmement libérale de la culture.
Mais, à la fois, il est juste,
et permet de faire marcher
la culture sur ses deux jambes :
sa jambe gauche comme bien public,
sa jambe droite
comme facteur d’attractivité.
La Villa Médicis,
c’est le rêve de beaucoup.
La voilà.
Quelques jours avant le premier
confinement, en mars 2020,
j’ai été nommé à Rome.
J’ai pris mes fonctions en septembre,
en plein lockdown.
Au cœur de Rome, un palais Renaissance -
vous le voyez là -
entouré de sept hectares de jardins.
Depuis 1803, la villa est
la propriété de la France.
Merci. Napoléon.
On n’a pas beaucoup l’occasion, dans
ces périodes, de dire cette phrase.
Merci Napoléon.
L’institution - l’Académie
de France à Rome -
Merci Napoléon car c’est lui qui l’achète.
L’Académie de France à Rome,
elle, est plus ancienne que 1803.
Elle a été créée par Colbert en 1666.
Je ne vais pas dire « Merci Colbert »,
je vais me faire beaucoup d’ennemis,
mais je le pense.
Depuis cette date, la France
accueille à Rome
artistes et créateurs les plus talentueux
pour un séjour aujourd’hui d’une année,
tous frais payés,
charge à eux de profiter de ce temps
désintéressé, de ce temps protégé,
pour créer, s'inspirer, explorer, tenter.
C’est un luxe extraordinaire,
vous en conviendrez.
Un luxe que seul un État
peut offrir à ses créateurs :
une année de recherche et création
sans aucune obligation de retour.
Car oui, nous sommes une résidence d'État,
la grande résidence.
Notre mission est en quelque sorte
une mission de service public.
Vous savez ce que c’est,
le service public ?
On a parfois un peu tendance à l'oublier.
Il y a « service » d’un côté.
Nous, notre domaine, c’est l’hospitalité.
Être une résidence,
c’est être un lieu d’hospitalité,
un lieu d’accueil, de partage,
un lieu qui fait communauté.
Public, ça veut dire
qui appartient à tous.
Un lieu comme le nôtre
peut d’ailleurs aussi être
un indicateur de la bonne santé
d’une démocratie.
Car seule une démocratie solide
n’a pas peur de financer
le travail de ses artistes
et favorise leur émancipation
et le développement de tous leurs projets,
même ceux qui dérangent,
qui irritent, qui piquent.
Aujourd'hui, à la Villa Médicis, nous
recevons environ 60 artistes par an.
Mais depuis l’année dernière,
nous avons aussi ouvert grandes
les portes de l’institution
à un autre public que les artistes.
Ce sont les « résidences pro ».
Elles s’adressent aux élèves
des lycées professionnels.
À la Villa Médicis, pendant quatre jours,
nous accueillons 300 élèves en même temps.
Ils viennent des régions de France.
En 2022, nous avons pour la première fois
lancé ce dispositif
et accueilli 300 élèves
de la région Nouvelle-Aquitaine
pour une résidence qui avait été
thématisée autour des métiers du bois,
l’une des filières d’excellence
de la région.
Cette année, ce ne sont pas
300 élèves, mais 600,
qui ont été accueillis
pendant deux semaines.
300 élèves de la région Grand Est
la première semaine
pour une résidence
autour des métiers de l’art de vivre.
Puis, la semaine suivante,
300 élèves de nouveau,
cette fois des lycées agricoles
de la région PACA Grand Sud,
autour d’une résidence thématisée
senteurs et saveurs.
À chaque fois, je vous le dis,
l’effet de sidération joue à plein.
Les élèves sont subjugués
par la beauté de la Villa Médicis,
mais aussi par la confiance et l’honneur
que nous leur faisons
en leur disant en quelque sorte :
« La Villa Médicis est à vous
pendant quatre jours. »
Le programme se compose de conférences,
d’ateliers, de rencontres, de visites.
Ce qui est important,
c’est que nous leur parlons d’eux,
de leurs sujets d’étude,
pas de nous.
C’est une logistique incroyable,
vous pouvez l’imaginer,
Nous les logeons
un peu partout dans la ville.
En huit jours, la villa sert
quasiment 5 000 repas.
Mais à la fin du compte,
la satisfaction est immense,
immense pour eux comme pour nous.
On fait un sondage rapide :
sur les 300, ils sont moins d’une dizaine
à être venus à Rome.
La plupart n’a jamais franchi
les frontières nationales.
Beaucoup n'ont jamais franchi
les frontières régionales.
Une institution peut -
Une institution doit être
un acteur social.
Vous le savez, la Villa Médicis,
c’est un chef-d’œuvre.
C'est un palais de la Renaissance.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est aussi
un palais de la République.
Quand on entend certains dire :
« Les palais de la République,
ce n’est pas pour nous. »
alors, c’est que nous avons
un problème de société,
un problème de vivre ensemble.
Il y a urgence à recoudre, à faire
du lien social, à s’occuper des autres,
de ceux qui n'ont pas toujours accès.
Et pour cela,
il faut faire un pas de côté,
ne pas s’en tenir à la seule feuille
de route que l’on vous donne.
Ma feuille de route,
c’est d’être une institution culturelle.
Si je reste avec mes œillères,
je ne peux pas regarder de côté.
Souvenez-vous, les institutions
ne sont pas des lieux,
les institutions sont des esprits.
Les institutions culturelles ne s'occupent
pas seulement de culture,
elles sont aussi des acteurs
économiques et sociaux.
Aller de l’avant, c’est bien,
c’est d’être ambitieux,
mais faire un pas de côté,
c’est être engagé, être créatif.
Cette leçon, je la tiens des artistes.
Je ne fais que reproduire dans mon domaine
l’enseignement que j’ai reçu
en les regardant.
Les artistes sont créatifs,
non pas parce qu’ils sont nés ainsi,
mais parce qu'ils regardent ailleurs.
Ils sortent sans cesse
de leur zone de confort.
Ils vont chercher les zones
de contraintes.
S'attaquer aux contraintes, c'est vouloir
modestement améliorer notre monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)